first day we got stuck on the first day
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome to game transect
7:00 a.m. in the morning
brem bambridge this is the Studios for
basically all of Winterfell
quite young and I had such a big
imagination in those scenes when I was
younger I would have really convinced
myself that I was there and it was
happening you know I'd never had any
experience of acting before I went to a
very theatrically
based drama school 33 hours of camera
trained in three years well then my
fourth hour in front of a camera was day
one on Game of Thrones my first day on
set was Castle black my first scene was
just a very quick scene where I'm
walking down the ramparts and I was so
nervous
Jesus my first job but this is like the
first thing I ever did and they said
we're no horse oh I was falling off the
horse trying to act still I remember my
first scene we shot from the pilot and
that was the Kings arrival and the King
rides in on horseback and he has to get
off this horse and his robe was enormous
the horse rides in he's like and then
hold everyone and then they run in with
thank you like a ladder they help him
down and run out with the lad and then
carry on I made me remember it was like
Sean Bean and Mark Adi and Lina and I
remember being so overwhelmed and
terrified I remember everybody clear I
remember baby Sophie and baby Maisie and
baby Isaac and now they're you know out
there full grown and here we are season
8 its cinematic we're making 10 hour
movies every year the fact that this is
really a full stop on this story is sad
because I think everyone's been so
invested in this story that we never
want to see this just come to a close
but it must and it will be good
everybody it's Charlie they dropped a
couple new behind the scenes promos for
Game of Thrones season 8 episode 1 we're
literally almost a day away from episode
1 getting here so we'll break some of
this down because the actors also talked
about the very first scene that they
filmed during season 8 in the very first
scene that they filmed on the series in
general way way back during season 1
there was also a really interesting
question that you guys asked me about
the night
in Winterfell in terms of what he can
and can't do using his magic so we'll
explain that to there's a lot of
historical context for Winterfell magic
bran the Builder going way way back to
the building of the wall if you're brand
new to my channel be sure to subscribe
to get all the season 8 videos we'll be
doing that weekly HBO now giveaway - all
you have to do to enter that is be a
subscriber and leave a comment on the
video the footage you see here is
basically Jon Snow Sansa bran Stark
Brienne of Tarth mists and I Jorah
Mormont Davos obviously if they're
sitting there then Emilia Clarke is
somewhere else - because we've actually
gotten a couple more pictures of this
scene that they're filming inside the
Great Hall of Winterfell apparently that
was the very first scene that they
filmed for season 8 you have Daenerys
Sansa John sitting at the table then in
this shot here you can actually see bran
sitting way off in the background right
next to the table on the left side of
the frame where Brienne is sitting next
to the little bear yawn and Davos Sansa
is still wearing her old outfit from
last season she hasn't got that leather
armor upgrade that you see in all those
other pictures that might come later in
the episode or maybe during episode 2
but Daenerys gets a whole bunch of
costume changes so it makes sense that
salsa but have a bunch of costume
changes as well
they talk about all their funny moments
during the very first scene that they
filmed during season 1 episode 1 for the
pilot episode I assume that they're
talking about the legit pilot and not
the scrapped pilot that everybody keeps
making fun of Nikolaj coster-waldau
Jaime Lannister was making fun of that
original pilot a little while ago during
an interview who knows if we'll ever get
to see footage of that but they keep
saying that it's terrible so I assume
that they won't release that the funny
thing about kit harington's very first
scene is he said he was up at the wall
so he'd already taken the black at that
point in the story just walking along
that corridor trying not to mess up but
then when sophie Turner is talking about
her very first scene as Sansa Stark
she's talking about when Robert
Baratheon arrived and Nikolaj
coster-waldau also talks about some of
the funny moments during that look
trying to get Robert off of his horse
like it took a whole bunch of crew
members they had to put a giant box next
to the horse just because his robe was
so long in a wound up being so awkward
that they had to cut around it I'm
assuming most of the other stark
children like Maisie Williams also had
their very first scene in this moment -
if salsa was having her first scene then
but you noticed Jon Snow in the
background of that shot so he was here
for that scene in Kit Harington was
filming before this so I'm assuming the
scene of Robert Baratheon and the
Lannisters meeting the stars happened
much later in the filming schedule than
some of this early stuff up at the wall
but like when John Bradley talks about
his first moments as Sam up on set he
didn't actually join the show till after
the pilot seems like the only person in
this video that talks about having his
first seen that wasn't during the pilot
the interesting thing about Amelia
Clarke's first day on said that she
talks about obviously it's a funny story
she kept falling off her horse because
she didn't know how to ride a horse she
was right out of school so it's just
really awkward she kind of chuckles her
way through it but this scene didn't
happen in the pilot episode they
actually put it during episode two so
maybe they just filmed it while they
were filming all these pilot scenes and
thought that it worked better during
episode two but if you ever go back and
you watch the pilot which you may have
done recently if you look at the scene
of Robert and Ned in the crypts going to
lyanna stark's statue you notice that
Sean beans hair looks very different
from the earlier scene when they're in
the courtyard that's because they reach
out a lot of that courtyard scene but
the scene of them in the crypts is from
the original pilot the reason why he
looks so different is because in that
original pilot they made Jaime Lannister
Ned Stark all the older characters look
a little bit younger than they do in the
final version of the pilot that we all
wound up seeing so sort of transitioning
to that big Winterfell night King theory
that people have been asking me you all
remember that first Game of Thrones
Season 8 trailer where we got footage of
Varys the women and children like Gilly
and baby Sam in the crypts hiding during
the big battle of Winterfell there are a
lot of people since then that have asked
me if the night King could use his magic
to raise all the stark dead in the
crypts like if the night king can raise
anybody that's dead
technically if you have a bunch of dead
bodies in this underground graveyard
couldn't he raise them as White's and
use them as fodder for his army the show
is also set precedent that the night
king can turn full skeletons into White
Walkers it doesn't have to be a freshly
dead person because season 4 episode 10
when they're all trying to enter the
three-eyed Ravens cape all those Ray
Harryhausen looking skeleton White's
come up like a bunch of landmines to try
and stop them from entering
if you know a little bit about the
origins of Winterfell its history
actually goes back to the creation of
the wall bran the Builder was supposed
to have built Winterfell after he built
the wall with the help of the Giants so
the Giants helped build the wall but the
Giants also helped build Winterfell the
thing is though is that most of the
original structures above ground from
that time have not survived bran the
Builder built the wall many thousands of
years ago way before the Andals invaded
the oldest part of Winterfell right now
that's still standing is the first
Keeffe that's where brand accidentally
caught Cersei and Jaime playing hide the
pickle and they got pushed out the
window things I do for love that was
built around the time of the Andal
invasion which was a couple thousand
years after the creation of Winterfell
so there's still like a lot of older
structures that just didn't survive
except for the godswood in the crypts
because bran the Builder built
Winterfell around the godswood for very
specific reason and if you notice the
crypts even though they're underground
are located right next to the godswood
so think about it this way if there was
special magic used to enchant the wall
when it was built
bran the Builder would have known about
that he also probably had some
enchantments laid on Winterfell that
helped protect it but this is many
thousands of years ago in in present-day
what just happened a couple seasons ago
bran was marked by the night king the
three-eyed raven said that because he's
marked you that's broken the enchantment
on the wall and he can now pass south
it's not enough to just use Vissarion to
melt the wall he had to break the
enchantment before he could use the
dragon to do that so if you consider
that the idea of the three-eyed Raven
the person that holds that enchantment
and keeps it in place is a transitive
thing like it's passed from one person
to another the three-eyed Raven tells
brand it's time for you to become me and
uploads his consciousness and all of his
knowledge in his magic into brand so
when the night King broke the
enchantment on the wall by marking brand
he also probably broke any other
enchantments that were laid around the
creation of the wall which would be the
stuff down at Winterfell so if there
were special enchantments protecting the
crypts at Winterfell to keep the dead
from rising again because of bran the
Builder built the crypts and he knew all
about the White Walkers that he would
probably try to do something to prevent
any of the stark dead from being used
against them but even if any magical
protections from the crypts are gone
think about it
this way from a practical standpoint
varus ghillie baby Sam will all probably
survive beyond the Battle of Winterfell
meaning that there probably aren't any
whites that are raised down there the
doors to the crypts are made of iron
wood which is really hard to burn with
anything but say like dragon fire or
vissarion's fire so it really is one of
the safest places to go in Winterfell
the crypts themselves are actually much
much larger underground than the
above-ground castle of Winterfell itself
so you said to imagine with this giant
iceberg of dead people underneath
Winterfell
the further down you go in the crypts
the older the stark dead so you get to
guess the brand the builder is probably
buried on the lowest level but they say
that the lower levels have all been
collapsed so hopefully that explains
just from a practical standpoint why
they probably won't be raising a whole
bunch of undead stark skeletons during
the Battle of Winterfell I may do one
more bonus video before episode 1
happens Sunday they're also doing a
special panel for the Mandalorian Star
Wars TV series so I'll do a trailer
video for that to leave all your
requests in the comments below or remind
everybody about the HBO now giveaway in
my episode 1 video on Sunday I named a
giveaway winner on Monday when I post
that episode 2 trailer video so while
you wait for everything click here for
all my Game of Thrones Season 8 trailer
videos and bonus videos and click here
for that brand new star wars episode 9
trailer congratulations everybody the
long wait is over I'll see you guys
tonight
you